yes for the last question so draws are
of course not a new thing in world
championship chess at all uh we have
gone like five years now without a
decisive game in the classical portion
in those five years there has been a
huge influx of new
chess fans who may not uh understand or
appreciate why we have so many draws
jan first and then magnus if you could
chime in afterwards to these new
uh new chess fans who may not understand
could you have a comment or a way of
explanation of why we see so many draws
well normally
you need uh
mistakes for a decisive result so
uh this
probably
[Music]
could tell you that uh players are not
making too many mistakes here and uh
yeah if the
you know if that
you play consistently yes you don't
blunder too often at least yeah uh in
general uh
chelsea's chance becomes quite a drawish
game yeah
yeah i would say that so much has been
has been written and said about this i
really don't have
have a lot a lot to add
we try
well we are happy that you do thank you
very much